let's say i have a path in the x y plane
that's essentially the unit circle
this is essentially the unit circle so
it's my y-axis
this is my x-axis
so my x-axis and our path is going to be
the unit circle
it's going to be the unit circle and
we're going to
traverse it just like that i'm going to
traverse it
clockwise
clockwise let's see
i think you get the idea
and so you get its equation it's the
unit circle so the equation of this is x
squared plus y squared is equal to one
has a radius of 1 unit circle
and what we're concerned with is the
line integral
the line integral over this curve c
over this curve see it's a closed curve
c
it's a closed curve c and it's actually
going in that direction
of
2y
dx
minus
minus 3x
minus 3x
d y
so we are probably tempted to use
green's theorem and y naught so let's
try so this is our path
so green's theorem tells us
that the integral
of some curve
f dot dr
f dot er over some path where f is equal
to where f is let me write it a little
bit not neater where f of x y
is equal to p of x y
i
plus q
of x y
j
that f dot that this integral is equal
to
is equal to the double integral
over the region this would be the region
under question in this example
over the region
of the partial of q
with respect to
x
the partial of q with respect to x
minus
minus the partial
of p
with respect to y
all of that
d a the differential of
area and of course the region is that
what i just what i just showed you now
you may or may not remember i did i made
what well what there's a slight subtle
thing in this which would give you the
wrong answer in the last video we said
that green's theorem applies when we're
going counterclockwise
counterclockwise notice even on this
little thing on the integral i made it
go counterclockwise in our example the
curve goes clockwise the region is to
our right green's theorem this applies
when the region is to our left
region
to
left
so in this situation when the region is
to our right and we're going clock so
this is counterclockwise counter
clockwise so in our example where we're
going clockwise the region is to our
right green's theorem is going to be the
it's going to be the negative of this so
in our example
we're going to have the integral of c
and we're going to go in the clockwise
direction so maybe i'll draw it like
that of f
dot
d r this is going to be equal to
the double integral over the region and
we could just swap these two of the
partial of p
with respect to y
minus the partial of q
with respect to x
d a so let's do that so this is going to
be equal to in this example the integral
over the region let's just keep it
abstract for now
we could start setting the boundaries
let's just keep the region abstract and
what is the partial of p with respect to
let's just remember this right here is
our
i think we could recognize right now
that this if if we take f dot dr we're
going to get this the dr contributes
those components the the f contr
contributes these two components so this
is p of x y
that is p of x y
and then this
is q
of x y and we've seen it i don't want to
go into the whole dot dr and take the
dot product over and over again i think
you can see that this is the dot product
of two vectors this are this is the x
component of f y component of f this is
the x component of d r y component of d
r
so let's take the partial of p with
respect to y take the derivative with
respect to y you get 2. derivative of 2i
is just 2.
so you get 2
and then minus the derivative of q with
respect to x derivative of this with
respect to x is minus 3. so we're going
to get minus 3 and then all of that
d a
and this is equal to the integral over
the region
over the region what's this is 2 minus
3 that's the same thing as 2 plus 3. so
it's the integral over the region of 5
d a 5 is just a constant so we can take
it out of the integral so this is going
to turn out to be quite a simple problem
so this is going to be equal to 5 times
the double
integral of over the region r
d a
now what is this thing what is this
thing right here
it looks very abstract but we can solve
this this is just the area
area
of the region
that's what that double integral
represents you just sum up all the
little das right that's a d a that's a d
a you sum up the infinite sums of those
little d a's over the region well what's
the area of this unit circle here we
just break out a little bit of ninth
grade actually even earlier than that
pre-algebra or or middle school geometry
area is equal to pi
r squared what's our radius it's a unit
circle our radius is one our radius is
one length is one so the area here is pi
so this thing over here
that whole thing is just equal to pi
so the answer to our line integral is
just five
pi which is pretty straightforward i
mean we could have taken the trouble of
setting up a double integral where we
take the anti-derivative with respect to
y first and write you know y is equal to
the negative square root of 1 minus x
squared y is equal to the positive
square root x goes from -1 to 1 but that
would have been super hairy and
a bunch of a huge pain we just realized
no this is just the area and and the
other interesting thing is i challenge
you to solve the same integral without
using green's theorem doing this the way
we you know actually take get generating
a parameterization for this curve going
in that direction taking the derivatives
of x of t and y of t multiplying by the
appropriate thing and then taking the
anti-derivative way hairier way hearier
than what we just did using green's
theorem to get 5 pi and remember the
reason why it wasn't minus 5 pi here is
because we're going in a in a clockwise
direction if we're going in a
counterclockwise direction we could have
applied the straight up green's theorem
and we would have gotten minus 5 pi
anyway hopefully you found that useful